what's up gamers it is January
[Music]
today we're playing language sir cooker
what this game has incredible Japanese
voice actors in it I mean they could
have just hired me dad I could die
I leave me that Grindr language sir if
you need voice actors you could have
just let your boy know okay well those
look actually terrifying what in the
world is they I don't know what it is
with Japanese laughs laughs in Japanese
all jokes aside this game has a rich
storyline with amazing graphics and a
huge world man so I don't know if you
guys knew this but I'm somewhat of a
strategical expert oh damn Jessica dude
okay so we're gonna do the arrow
formation and let's just hope it works
out as we're gonna tap to attack love
with one ghost hero attack okay okay I
actually love how Japanese assists
garage see I could have done the garage
I've read the Sun Tzu
oh yeah the Chinese strategist and one
of the things from that book it's funny
because people still take the art of war
into man I'm growing enough on a tangent
here it's it's a book written by a
Chinese war general and he tells his
secrets and all his rules for war and
one of the rules for war is to never let
your enemy fight to the death always
make your enemy things that you have an
opportunity to escape because if you
fight against someone that things are
fighting to the death they fight
obviously much stronger so you should
make it seem like your opponent has a
chance to escape to actually get them I
don't know just interesting I know a
thing or two about strategy in video
games because I'm a gamer right well we
have the hot girls on our side so
obviously we're gonna win Oh oh my god
Oh Sugoi it did one damage in him laughs
in Japanese this is my voice six days on
enemy Oh where are our arms oh there
they are
sorry okay if she was T posing me she's
lost Charisse
you sound like a drink for those who you
are not familiar with language there's a
background story it has history dating
back to the 90s how cool is that what
would you do if an enemy raided you
while you were gathering supplies okay I
read Sun Tzu the rule art of war it goes
like this
the number one rule of art of war know
when to fight know when to fight your
battle you retreat what is the most
important factor when creating an
unbeatable team to have a strong general
strategic versatility now you're
supposed to say you're right Wow I can't
believe you have with so much background
knowledge in Chinese warlord in history
the meaning of life come on girl please
to get what my heart desires yeah okay
she looks like Zeus
I played similar games like this when I
was young it's really cool to have it on
your phone and I also wanna most of all
show off the arrow formation just so I
can show my gamer bros how it's done oh
god we're surrounded defeat all enemies
okay so it's time to use Swedish warfare
[Music]
my magic in is I gonna me is from great
distance she just said she wasn't a
sorcerer
we're gonna go ahead and attack these
guys
arrow formation come on it's so cute
when they night we just attack okay so
we're strong they're weak attack come on
guys but will we defeat their archers oh
yes we did okay excellent I should go
there right I don't know
Stan oh wait there's more over there
damn it
[Music]
yes okay it's it's fighting time we
should get these guys no no no no okay
let's get these guys you see with my
strategic advantages I can easily
destroy beat my opponent enemy I just
love his life one of the things with
that something that I read it's always
about the terrain advantage in the book
and how you should always apply that and
you should you should always apply that
to your to your tactics one of the most
important things and how you should
attack your opponent in different if
they're crossing a river or if they're
in different situations and so this game
as well has terrain adventures and
similar aspects to it so it's really
interesting in my opinion that you can
actually apply old military ancient
military strategy strategy to an actual
modern video game I don't know I think
that's cool ohm it is glowing so she is
the source and he may I say she's very
hot we leveled up yah that's yay in
Japanese you probably don't know that I
actually really like that as Japanese
dialogue cuz I'm trying to study
Japanese gives me emergent we love to
move there for a while and live there
for a while that would be the dream oh
so here's the map it's supposed to be
huge
let's think if they have a lot of stuff
to do it's always overwhelming when you
ladies
a game through somebody needs stuff okay
so here we go crossing river great point
to attack perhaps I really Lancer on the
left you use your own class priority to
your advantage
what is my clients priority but I can
get infantry really easily using a
priority against class types can be very
effective okay so it is I'm I'm strong
against two cavalry stronger yes even
dream forgeries strong is Lancer okay
okay okay we just got absolutely
destroyed no nevermind that means I need
a toilet break no way you guys bother
attack them destroy you anyway it's too
strong yeah uh yeah we did it guys we
open the chest what do we get 300 gold
and some basic XP alright so relieving
tuvalu village and we're going towards
hey we can do quests on the way okay I
guess we're doing it oh so she can
attack from range
we're fighting slime hey okay hey still
got him so obviously there's a lot of
depth to the strategy of this game I
know I'm kind of parroting it just from
the commercials but this is actually
that type of game so different soldier
categories like Knights and Hawk riders
and fighters all have different
advantages and disabilities based on who
they're fine
cerissa so you have to be smart to play
this game at least 5 IQ points I'm very
smart that's what I'm saying I read a
book once ok imagine learning Japanese
just from playing a game like this you
start you'll speak normally like like we
always get to this point we're in a
video where I'm just enjoying the game
and I just play the game I don't know
what else to tell you guys I just need
to progress a little bit alright enemy
turn they're all dead they have red
slime they reproduce yeah we did it
victory download language sir link in
the descriptions a new tube can be a
strategic mastermind like me so there's
training summon iron unlock anything
we're fighting an enemy an enemy an
enemy a girl we're fighting an enemy
girl oh we have a bridge I didn't mean
it that way I meant now we have a
strategic advantage that's why I'm
excited about the bridge Jesus Christ
it's giving me a lot of miss Lu though
legit oh god I'm actually dying because
I used to play a game like this when I
was a kid I don't remember what it was
called I mean this game dates back to
the 90s and maybe it was I already
played I don't know bonds of friendship
damn
damn he's a special attack oh so he's
nearby another character he's stronger
but I want to get the chest okay you
guys okay there we go
there you go so strong Jesus Christ
wow so beautiful get a flavor like
angels all the girls are so pretty new
function functioning like summon okay we
[Music]
look Sue's who are we gonna get Pikachu
come on go Scott where are they enemies
OU's looking girls my name is Scott of
Saluda I'm studying to become Knight and
I'm willing to lend you my aid for my
further experience so we have more than
one hero now oh we do okay so we can
upgrade them with stars okay
insufficient items well damn oh so you
click here to upgrade I've done so yeah
each character have like a skill tree
you can upgrade I mean I'm barely
scratching the surface of the game like
this but I'm gonna level up her as long
oh wow look at this oh my god so I guess
you discover where the clouds are later
that's really dope a one sign it's the
currency in this game bread that's how
you know it's a real gaming game for
real gamers if you literally collect
bread oh god it's a bridge but wait
that's good for us see they're crossing
the water now we should attack them
according to Sun Tzu oh you did yes yes
we did it I take it back I can't do the
voice acting
I feel strangely attracted to the smell
of that girl Oh
it was a trap that will languish there a
mother which sponsored it solidity Good
King answered the code PewDiePie for 30
but that's not up true but you should
check out this game I highly recommend
it it's actually really fun it's a
genuinely well developed game and I'm
really happy to have
as always as always all my products I
recommend are good that's it for me for
now however hope you guys enjoyed this
video smash liked and I'll see you guys
tomorrow bye Johnny if you want more
information regarding language sir they
also have a Facebook page at language
serein that has more info